you always were a Yankees cap a lot and
it was curious yeah picture of it here
have you become a Yankees fan yeah oh I
have to oh this is this picture this guy
right next to me is a young comedian
Kevin iams big community in France I say
hi he's watching us right now
[Applause]
Kevin what Kevin would know that's
chairman again that's true you a you a
Yankee fan why didn't cap know I have to
say I love this hat and I don't know
anything about baseball I don't know the
rules I don't know the players names I
don't know that I don't know anything
and just where there's caps because
they're cool and comfortable and and I'm
famous so I have a hat just in France
here I have no hat go yeah but to you
you we saw this you have a to-do list a
post-it have this oh this is a real
post-it that you had learn English get a
visa moved to America and at the very
bottom understand baseball rules why do
you want to understand baseball rules
you don't seem to even care about the
sport I don't know it's just
that's funny when I wear this hat I
remember when the guy came up to me
because people the baseball fans they
want to engage me in conversation yeah
so I found a trick because I can't talk
about baseball I respect you guys but I
can't talk about baseball so I found a
little trick he came up to me this guy
is a Yankees what do you think is gonna
happen tonight
I said hey don't get me started
[Laughter]
it works great that's fantastic that
works for everything everything where've
you been tonight Conan who get me
started
what do I get like comments I get people
get mad at me of that something
sometimes I'm like at the airport
rogue hot ya know get mad I like this
hat it's just a heart yeah you can't do
that don't know you they think that
you're making a real commitment to the
Yankees no yeah but it's I love the Hat
you